I visited the home of Zachary Taylor who
was the 12th President of the United
States in office from 1849 to 1850 the
house was built in 1790 by his father
Richard Taylor who fought in the
Revolutionary War Between 1775 and
1781 I'll also show you some of the area
that surrounds the house which is pretty
much all a residential neighborhood
today and about two blocks away there is
a 50t monument with a LIF siiz
statue of Zachary Taylor on top of it
that was built in
1883 and right next to that stands his
maam so this is all located in the
eastern part of Louisville
Kentucky this whole area surrounding the
house was originally a 400 acre estate
owned by Richard Taylor Zachary's father
interestingly this 400 acre plot of land
was given to Richard Taylor by the
government for his service in the
American Revolutionary War the main
house was built in 1790 and prior to
that the family had lived in a log cabin
on the
property also about two blocks away if
we zoom in
here there is a cemetery that both
Zachary and his father are buried at and
if we zoom in here we can see the maum
and next to the maum stands the monument
and next to all of this stands another
interesting estate called Locust Grove
which is famous for being a Gathering
Place for Le and Clark right after they
finished their famous expedition in 1806
I'll make a separate video about Locust
Grove later it's it's quite large and
many of the original buildings are still
standing
today so let's go ahead and get to the
footage of Zachary Taylor's house and
its surrounding
area
[Music]
la
we are currently driving through the
Indian Hills
neighborhood of Louisville
[Music]
Kentucky uh Richard Taylor Zachary
Taylor's father he uh served in the
Revolutionary War he started out as a uh
second
lieutenant in uh
1775 I
believe and uh let me see if this is the
street we're looking for a
patchy Road and that looks like the
street anyway this
street goes right on
to let me see if my memory serves me
correctly I believe Zachary Taylor's
house where his boyhood home that is is
right oh there it is right there I can
see
[Music]
it
the
[Music]
p
so
okay we are now at the Zachary Taylor
National
[Music]
Cemetery
and somewhat of a small Cemetery I'm
going to jump out here in a second and
do some filming there's a monument I
believe up the road here that was built
in
1883 and uh let me go ahead
and park it and we'll go check that
out
[Music]
Hal
la
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
la
n
[Music]
oh